take a ride in emily dickinson's chariot  but beware  there's no turning back  because i could not stop for death  by emily dickinson  because i could not stop for death  he kindly stopped for me  the carriage  held but just ourselves and immortality  we slowly drove  he knew no haste and i had put away  my labor  and my leisure too for his civility  we passed a school  where children strove at recess  in the ring  we passed the fields of gazing grain  he passed the setting sun  or rather  he passed us  the jews do quivering  and chill  for only gossamer my gown  my tippet only tool  we paused before a house that seemed a  swelling  of the ground  the roof was scarcely visible  the cornice in the ground  since then  tis centuries  and yet  feel shorter than the day  i first surmised  the horse's heads  were toward eternity  for more poetry that helps us make sense  of the most inexplicable parts of life  here's our series  there's a poem for that  which one speaks to you